[Música]
nossa alimentação é como abrir uma
janela com vista panorâmica da nossa
própria história tanto de sujeito quanto
da sociedade como é um ato afetivo e
psicológico e político é um
comportamento natural mas que está
completamente moldado pela cultura e
pelos nossos afetos às nossas memórias
alimentares elas incluem categorias
simbólicas como o tempero da mãe o tempo
da volta o sabor da comida de casa
aquele gosto por outro lado como é um
ato natural é obrigatório
a gente precisa comenta continuar vivo
então a comida é a conexão mais próxima
que a gente tem com a natureza tão
fundamental quanto respirar
do ponto de vista das sociedades a gente
sabe que aquelas consideradas de sucesso
são as que foram capazes de alimentar o
seu povo e além disso produzir riqueza
o território brasileiro e foi descoberto
no momento da história que a gente
buscava pelas especiarias pelos temperos
nas índias e além disso boa parte da
nossa história como colônia está
relacionada à cana de açúcar ao café ou
cacau
então a gente pode afirmar com certeza
que o planeta hoje é formado por uma
legião de famintos
só que uns muito mais amigos que os
outros
segundo a onu são 824 milhões de pessoas
em situação de fome no mundo
só no brasil são 5,4 milhões
um planeta de famintos que vive um
momento da história em que o agravamento
de conflitos civis ea ascensão de
governos autoritários literalmente
esvaziam o prato de quem tem fome não
falta comida no mundo
muito pelo contrário a gente hoje produz
mais do que precisa
o que falta é acesso ao alimento
produzido um terço de tudo que a gente
produzir desperdiçado 30% de todo o
alimento produzido no planeta vai pro
lixo e junto com esse alimento vai
também a água o solo eo combustível que
foi utilizado tanto para produzir quanto
a transportar e aí essa bagunça em que a
comida vai para o lixo mas não chega no
prato de quem tem fome nos coloca diante
de uma pergunta que é fundamental
ou seja como é que a gente vai fazer pra
comer no futuro
em decorrência disso a gente se pergunta
qual o meu papel como cozinheiro como
restaurante
como cidadão nesse cenário será que a
gente precisa novas categorias
alimentares como as farinhas de insetos
será que algum dia comida de verdade vai
ser direito de todos vai continuar sendo
um privilégio de gente como a gente que
tem grana pra isso acho que a questão do
alimento da alimentação do planeta está
completamente relacionado ao fato da
gente não se relacionar
a gente precisa olhar para a nossa
comida que quando a gente olha a gente
percebe que o modelo de produção
hegemônico no momento ou seja a
monocultura controlada por mega
corporações que conta não só a terra mas
também a venda da semente do
fertilizante e agrotóxico esse modelo já
parte de um princípio de desperdício que
é a perda da biodiversidade das riquezas
da água do sol
quanta riqueza gente já chegou em nome
da soja
falando da fauna da fora das plantas
alimentícias não convencionais daquelas
com propriedades terapêuticas dos
territórios de comunidades tradicionais
indígenas no meio da cadeia os centros
de distribuição de alimentos ceasa em
caminhão do lixo todos os dias toneladas
de alimentos com capacidade de alimentar
são os feios e machucadinhos que já não
já não estão mais rápidos do comércio
é claro que a gente pode criar
alternativas e seguir vários exemplos aí
criando um banco de areia
a redistribuição mas tem uma pergunta
anterior que é porque a gente produz tem
antecedentes como consumidores a gente
relaciona o tempo inteiro comida em
excesso do campo as mesmas a gente
celebra a fartura é melhor sobrar do que
faltar ea gente se pergunta de onde vem
essa fantasmática qual foi a última vez
que faltou em datas comemorativas por
exemplo a gente produzir muito mais
comida do que precisa agora no natal a
gente vai comer é do ea barriga e vai
sobrar comida que quase alcançando novo
e essa ética com o alimento se repete
cotidianamente em geral
nós não planejamos nossas contas a gente
comprar mais do que precisa
o critério para definir se você levar um
ingrediente para casa saldo bancário não
impacto que ele jogou no planeta e com
relativa tranquilidade a gente aceita o
fato de que a comida estragar lhe seja o
restinho de comida que ficou no fundo da
geladeira ou aquele legumes fruta que a
companhia não sabe usar e aí a gente
precisa fazer um raciocínio que a gente
esquece que assim o custo desse
desperdício desses 30% já está incluso
no preço que você paga mas me parece
óbvio que a indústria tenha o interesse
em diminuir esse desperdício dentro da
própria cadeia o que pra mim ainda não é
tão óbvio é que a gente tem esse mesmo
cuidado dentro de casa
e aí eu me pergunto por que que a gente
trata comida desse jeito
dia após dia a gente tá perdendo a nossa
autonomia culinária que é exatamente a
capacidade de reconhecer e produzir a
própria comida
então a gente está muito distante da
terra e não sabe praticamente nada sobre
plantio eo próximo passo é o
distanciamento da cozinha
o problema é que esse distanciamento
traz uma perda muito importante que a da
sabedoria popular emancipatória o
conhecimento das nossas avós
esse conhecimento de quem sabia sair do
leite e chegar num queijo passando pelas
natas pela manteiga e todos os outros
derivados
a sabedoria de quem usava
gente dos pés à cabeça porque sabe
exatamente quanto que custou produzir
aquele alimento e qual pais todos os
processos que ele passou antes de chegar
o fogão
a gente precisa se relacionar com a
comida e lembrar aquela vem da terra e
de graça porque quando a gente esquece
isso a gente vai se tornando cada vez
mais dependente da indústria que ao
decidir o que vai produzir numa
determinada região do planeta
decidiu também que a gente vai comendo o
brasil está voltando do mapa da fome
isso acontece porque a gente não quer
mais se preocupar com comida
nessa relação distanciada com com
alimento fazer a própria comida cozinhar
em casa muitas vezes é um sacrifício um
esforço ou então um delírio gastronômico
em que vale tudo em nome do meu prazer
tem uma frase que eu escuto com muita
freqüência que é quase anedótico que
assim nossa voz e cozinheiro eu não sei
nem fritar um ovo ea mulher realmente
muito como isso mas além de ser uma
sentença ele também foi denunciado
quando a gente acha que está tudo bem
legal pra outras pessoas ou até o
maquinário industrial
toda essa produção da nossa comida a
gente não quero incomodar com isso
o planeta caótico do jeito que está a
gente quer que a alimentação tem uma
relação de prazer que seja está gravável
que tenha todas as possibilidades e não
quero pensar no impacto que o meu prato
de comida causa do planeta
a gente está voltando para o mapa da
fome
isso acontece porque todos os anos a
gente forma centenas de cozinheiros como
mãe com imenso repertório técnico dentro
das cozinhas mas com uma minúscula
capacidade de olhar o seu entorno e
entender quais conexões com o alimento
faz a gente sabe um monte por exemplo
sobre o grão de café mas a gente sabe
quase nada sobre o que esse ingrediente
representou a nossa história
o que ele representou e representa na
nossa economia
será que as únicas informações
relevantes sobre o ingrediente são sabor
textura características de cozimento
será que tá entender melhor esse
consumir esse mercado não preciso dar
uma olhada um pouco maior
a gente vive uma cena neste momento da
história que é uma absurda produção de
conteúdo de receita mas é uma minúscula
a propagação de conteúdo sobre o
conhecimento do ingrediente como ele
funciona
vou dar um exemplo vai ficar mais claro
se aprende a fazer uma lasanha de
abobrinha na internet e aí está amando
aquele piada né
só que tem um dia que você vai fazer
faltam três ingredientes e porque faltam
três ingredientes daquela receita
abobrinha vai poder se ali na proteína
até ela tá podre o suficiente para você
jogar no lixo sem sentir culpa
aliás a gente vê é aqui na região a
goiaba e mamão acontecendo no pé passa
embaixo vai do mercado comprar porque
parece que há um pouco de medo assim né
dessa comida que na cidade onde eu vejo
parece até meio suja o alimento está
virtualizado
quando eu não entendo para os processos
que ele passou até chegar na minha mesa
desperdiçar é o único caminho
nós pensamos muito porque nos conhecemos
muito seja o quanto o ingrediente custou
do planeta e recursos naturais para além
da medida a moeda seja como utilizar
esse ingrediente a nossa fazia na comida
de pobre salvar fazia comida de verdade
é outra coisa que a gente precisa
resgatar agora não são esses
ingredientes do outro lado do mundo
super fetichizadas que
é tão bom quanto é legal toda essa
gastronomia o que a gente precisa
recuperar é a relação ética com um
alimento que a gente tinha quando a
produção do alimento é do cetro
organizador da vida
o alimento não é mais nosso centro
ele é mais uma coisa que a gente faz é
continuar produzindo outra coisa
ou já se reforçar e trazer para
continuar produzindo outra coisa nessa
relação distanciada fica muito difícil
pensar o cenário mas a possibilidade
incentivar a produção local completa o
produtor aqui perto de mim onde eu não
preciso litros de combustível para
transportar 2018
existe uma mudança na relação de consumo
eu preciso me relacionar com a comida
com quem produz com quem fornece com
quem enfrenta os mesmos problemas que
enfrenta
eu costumo dizer que não há
sustentabilidade sem relação não adianta
ficar sentadinho esperando o momento que
a sustentabilidade vai chegar porque não
vai rolar aquela aconteça a gente
precisa se relacionar com problema
a gente precisa lembrar que a comida vem
da terra e de graça e que nós
alimentamos os produtos da terra e que
quando a gente tira algo da prateleira
do supermercado
a gente está demandando que uma nova
produção seja feita e que com isso novos
recursos sejam utilizados
a boa notícia é que por mais caótico que
o mundo esteja quando a gente muda o
nosso padrão de consumo alimentar a
gente para de incentivar práticas
predatórias de desmatamento ou seja a
fome no mundo tem tudo a ver com a gente
porque a gente tem uma posição de
influência nessa cadeia comida é feita
para quem consome a comida
no final das contas a nossa lista de
compras
ela funciona exatamente como o título de
eleitor
ela é o voto cotidiano que afirma paula
modelo de sociedade que você apoia
obrigado
[Aplausos]